So when I was 15, I remember going to my mom and sort of telling her like, I'm
having a hard time like seeing what's in front of me.
I'm having a hard time seeing the board.
I didn't think much of it, you know, because I didn't really just didn't think much
of it. But I realized I'm sitting in the back of class and where I like to sit, I
couldn't see anything. And then it really got sort of serious when I started to
drive and I realized that some signs that I think I might be should be able to see
or my friends have told me about that I'm not seeing, something's not right.
And so I went to the doctors, went to the eye doctor, and they did all the little
checks. They put the little thing on your face, and they do all the dialing, and you
read the lines and the letters and all that kind of stuff.
And I didn't think much of it.
And they told me, flip the lenses, and which one is better.
And you did the whole process of getting fitted for a pair of glasses.
And I thought nothing of it until I walked in the day and picked them up.
And I picked them up, and I looked at them, and for the first time, I put glasses
on, and all of a sudden, the world completely changed.
Things were sharper. I could see things that I didn't even know existed from across
the room. My entire perception, my entire reality really started to change because
now I could actually see the way I was supposed to see.
When we're talking about worldviews, the most simplistic way to sort of see
it and understand it is simply this, is by looking at the world through a set of
lenses. And how you look through those lenses sort of dictates how you see the
world. World view, how I view the world, right?
So, but more than that, worldviews and what you should start
to now see through the worldview questions that were introduced, that worldviews are
foundational. They are life-shaping questions about reality.
See, it's not just the pair of glasses that I'm looking at through to see the world.
It's literally how I'm interpreting it and how I'm living as a result of that view.
So all those students should see very quickly through some of the activities in the
Bible study that a biblical worldview has a profound impact on how we live.
For this week, I want you to keep three really important things in mind
as you work through this lesson.
Now, we've talked about things like what apologetics is and we've talked about what
faith is. We've talked about what truth is.
We've talked about logic. We've laid this foundation so that you can continue to
move through this study, but now we need students to really understand what it means
to see the world through a particular lens.
But we don't just want them to see the world through the Christian lens.
We want them to understand the world through a couple other popular ways of seeing,
naturalism and pantheism. Then we're going to talk about what it looks like from a
monotheistic worldview because the way in which other people see the world is is
going to vastly, widely influence how your students start to see the world.
So when people who see the world differently are involved in making movies and
writing music and doing art and making TV shows and whatever else it is, and writing
and books and everything else,
that worldview is going to get communicated to your students.
So they need to start to be able to see that.
But before we can start into all of that, there's three really important things I
want you to keep in mind because there's some things that are going to come up here
that are going to be pretty impactful.
Number one, don't assume your students have a biblical worldview.
Now, if your group has what most are going to call themselves Christians, let's say
your group is a typical youth group that has the majority of Christians, you might
automatically just sort of assume that, hey, my students have a Christian worldview
or a biblical worldview. That may not necessarily be the case.
You're going to discover that your students have some inconsistencies and some
contradictions in their worldview.
In fact, worldviews are often, if you can imagine, going to a buffet restaurant.
Worldviews are often like that now.
I mean, think about all the information that we have.
Think about what's available to our students via the internet.
That as soon as they want to know something, what do we ask?
We ask Google. We ask Siri. We ask the questions over the internet to figure out the
answers to our questions rather than asking, you know, we're going to a library and
looking at a book and considering the source.
We just ask. And we look at the top five views on Google, and we go with it.
Our students have more information available to them than any other time in history.
So what happens is students have what I call a buffet worldview.
You walk into a restaurant that's got a buffet, you grab a plate and you just
start taking food that looks good and you just start grabbing whatever that you
want. And then when you're done with that, you get rid of that plate, you go back to
the buffet and you grab different stuff that looked good the next time.
Or maybe you go back and grab some seconds of stuff that you really liked, but you
grab it all together and you just eat at a very low discounted price, right?
So you may just automatically think that they have a biblical worldview because
somewhere along that buffet, there are pieces of Christianity, pieces of Scripture
in their worldview. But then as you explore deeper, especially your small group
leaders, as they explore deeper and get more into conversations and build deeper
relationships with those students, they're going to discover that there's some
significant inconsistencies. Now, don't panic.
That's okay. Because as we move through this process, we'll hopefully iron
out those inconsistencies and help them and guide them through a more consistent
worldview.
That's what the actual worldview questions are designed to do, right?
By asking those four questions, it draws out what they think, but it also reveals
the flaws in thinking in a nice, gentle, respectful way.
So make sure, encourage, and hopefully you've created this environment already,
but encourage your students to answer honestly.
We don't want the answers that they think we want to hear.
We want their actual answers, whatever they may be.
So don't freak out if you hear something that just totally you did not expect.
Number two,
worldviews have to be coherent and consistent.
Even though the buffet sounds really good and it works for some, at least seems like
it works for some, it doesn't. And over time that will cause problems.
That's why you go back for seconds and you take different things because it's a
search for trying to figure out the best possible combination.
That doesn't work. So you're going to, you know, throughout this process we're going
to be helping students understand that this is what makes Christianity so
compelling, is that it's entirely coherent and it's entirely consistent.
And finally, don't expect students to change their worldview right away.
Just because you see that they have a different worldview, or they have
inconsistencies in their worldview, or there's some questions in their worldview,
and you present even at the end of this 32 weeks, if you're presenting the Christian
worldview, don't expect them that they are just going to go, oh, I'm going to put on
a whole new pair of glasses, and I'm going to see the world totally different.
It doesn't work that way. In fact, it doesn't work that way at all.
In fact, changing how we see the world is not as easy as just changing a
prescription on a pair of glasses.
It's a huge, huge adjustment. In fact, sometimes so
big that it causes discomfort. It causes anxiety because people to change how
you see the world and is to really change almost your entire reality of how you
understand things and how you answer big questions in life and how you interact with
people. That's a lot of change, so be patient with your students.
Walk alongside them. Help them figure it all out.
All right, so over the last several weeks, we've sort of challenged you with a lot
of adjustments that you kind of need to make within the context of your group.
We've talked about the idea of building relationships being the most important
thing, Not just the relationship between your students and Christ, but your
relationships between you and your students.
That there needs to be that sense of trust built.
We've also talked about the idea of really just fostering a community where
questions and doubt are welcomed.
We've talked about this idea of worldviews and what this looks like and being
patient with your students in determining what their worldview actually is and to
not be surprised if somehow their worldview doesn't quite line up with what
you thought. And we've even talked about sort of how to get rid of that barrier wall
between what you're talking about in terms of objective truth and their view of
truth in a very post-modern, relativistic, post-truth kind of world that they're
consistently exposed to in school and in media and whatnot.
That's a lot. That's a lot to take in over the course of four weeks.
So now would be a really really good time if you haven't done so already to check in
with your small group leaders checking with your other leaders to see how these
things are going to make sure that the community is starting to coalesce together
the students feel like they can ask the questions check in with some of your key
students who have the pulse of the youth group to sort of get a feel for where
everybody is and are you accomplishing these goals it might look to you like
you are, but don't be surprised if there's a little bit of angst and a little bit of
a struggle. But don't panic either if it's not happening just yet.
The important thing right now is to keep your hand on the pulse of your group so
that you can navigate it as you go and you are increasing that level of trust and
increasing the student's ability to ask the tough questions.
You suddenly might fall back into old questions that were asked in
different lessons, because now students finally feel like they can ask that
particular question or answer that particular question that we're asking of them.
So just be ready for it. Check in with your small group leaders.
Check in with a couple of students to figure out where everything is and strategize
as to how you might move forward.
But remember, when we're talking about worldviews, the three things you need to keep
in mind is that your students may not have necessarily a biblical worldview that you
think that they have, but their worldview needs to not be a buffet but coherent and
consistent. And don't expect them to change it right away.
Be patient. And I think that's probably the most important piece is be patient with
them. Pray with them. Continue to walk alongside them to help them understand truth
and how it fits in and how truth is going to change their reality and how
understanding scripture and their understanding of truth is going to actually change
their worldview slowly but also profoundly.